hello everyone and welcome to another
spectacular game uh between yani punish
and magnus carlsen it's from the uh
world rapids championship in 2016 in uh
from qatar dojo and it's it is the first
game that magnus actually won against
nepo
nipple
including all time formats so it took
magnus some 14 years and uh 10 games to
uh to finally crack that
armor nepo is wearing
and it's quite a quite an interesting
game so you guys are going to enjoy it
let's check it out and then as usual
we're going to discuss the standings and
you know a little bit about everything
so nipple uh with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have c6 by magnus going for
the carl khan defense knight to c3 d5
attacking the center and knight to f3 uh
so magnus captures in the center we have
d captures knight captures and now
knight to f6 attacking this knight here
and offering white to
double black spawns on the f6 square so
this is what nepo goes for it is the
standard way to play this it captures on
f6 and now d4 white grabs more space in
the center and now the ship to d6 so now
black of course wants the castle and uh
nipple prepares castling as well with
bishop to e2 it's an interesting choice
bishop to d2 3 uh seems like an obvious
choice why allow uh
black to do anything along this diagonal
but okay uh he goes for bishop to a2 and
this is something that we will discuss
throughout the game so here uh magnus
castles nepal castles and now rook to e8
developing the rook and now c4 so this
is all very standard stuff grabbing more
space here uh magnus goes knight to d7
the idea is now you want to play knight
to f8 to g6 and then uh well from from
there the knight will be very very
useful uh and there are a couple of
games that reach this position uh known
moves are something like rook to e1
bishop to e three's unknown move even c5
are charging the bishop here is a known
move but nipple just plays bishop to d3
and it's already very weird okay this is
a rapid game so he's probably trying to
take magnus uh you know out of his
comfort zone maybe trying something
weird
but it's
a loss of a tempo at best so this
position has never been reached again i
know you guys are interested in that and
magnus just continues with knight to f8
of course queen to c2 going for that h7
pawn is coming so magnus has it
on f8 guarding the pawn but also just
knight coming to g6 will also guard the
pawn so here h3 not allowing bishop to
g4 and now that knight's the g6 we have
queen to c2 by nipple now the knight
can't move because you will lose that h7
pawn and queen to a5 by magnus a nice
developing with the queen now getting
ready to develop the bishop and also
somehow get the other rook into the game
so c5 challenging the bishop here bishop
back to b8 you don't want to play bishop
c7 because that will really create huge
problems for you imagine something like
b4
attacks the queen you sacrifice upon and
then rook to b1 and what is your queen
doing here queen a5 bishop
d2 and uh well there's there's simply no
square left uh for your queen uh you're
gonna have to play something like knight
bishop to h2 check uh give up the bishop
just to free up the c7 square for your
queen so you have to be careful here so
this should be back to b8 by magnus and
now the ship to d2 chasing away the
black queen queen back to d8 and now
rook f to e1 and now magnus could trade
on the e file but if you do this then
just captures capture snipple has the
rook very nicely placed on the open e
file and magnus still has to figure out
how to get uh the bishops out of the way
so the rook can finally enter the game
because you want to play rook 8 at some
point to challenge white's rook so
magnus goes bishop to e6 first he says
all right i first have to figure out how
to get the other rook into the game and
then we're gonna discuss trading on the
e file uh and now you might expect
something like b4 why not grabbing more
space here or a4 then maybe b4 and b5
but nipple plays bishop to c4 so it's a
very very unusual uh treatment of the
bishop bishop e2 followed by bishop to
d3 followed by bishop to c4 now offering
a trade of light square bishops magnus
just continues with the knight back to a
f8
now if
bishop captures we may we might even
capture with the knight here so rook
eight to d1 and now bishop to c7 now
magnus wants to
develop the queen and finally get this
rook into the game so queen to b3
putting pressure on b7 and also now with
a triple attack here on the e6 square so
here magnus finally trades bishop
captures queen captures and queen to d7
so a lot of squares for this bishop to
now be just absent from the game uh but
okay nepal continues with b4 now we want
to play a4 b5 and grab more space on the
queen side we have knight to g6 by
magnus now with the absence of the light
square bishop we want to bring this
knight to e7 and then to d5 and on d5
this will be a monster knight so here we
have a4 nipple continues with his queen
side plants knight to e7 and now b5 so
attacking the queen side knight to d5
magnus gets his knight to this beautiful
outpost uh and now
it's uh well it's a very uh tense
position you have to be very very
careful here do you trade on e8
definitely an option do you prepare
would rook to be one to maybe uh capture
or maybe even push some points on the
queen side uh it's uh well a matter of
preference nepo decides to capture on c6
right away and magnus recaptures b
captures in c6 and now queen to a6 so
now
this queen is uh needed here because
a lot of things are isolated here on the
queen side and you might have trouble
defending them but for the moment you
really don't and the magnus takes this
absence of the queen
from the game into consideration and
decides to perform a kingside attack so
he starts with the g5 now his idea is h5
g4 we're going to open up the position
our bishop and queen are nicely slicing
over
to the king's side so good things should
happen here if we manage to get these
two moves in so nipple goes knight to h2
now he doesn't have to worry about any
h5 g4 coming with tempo and now magnus
makes a very interesting decision it's
definitely one of those decisions that
you should remember
and try to employ in your own games
to the best of your abilities and that
is bishop captures on h2 so we're gonna
check out this move once again in slow
motion because uh it's a really
important idea so this is a monster
bishop you do not want to give up this
bishop just for nothing uh the thing is
magnus gives it up for this knight
because this knight could become a very
powerful piece if it comes to g4 could
be attacking a lot of very important
squares here now by eliminating it we
play king captures and king the g7 and
now we basically have this knight
against the bishop this is now the game
this knight on d5 versus the bishop on
d2 because the rooks can be traded off
at will you don't really have to take
rooks into consideration and the queen
doesn't really have all that many um
ideas here on the queen side so this is
what magnus did now it's this knight
that's beautiful against this bishop
that's really not doing all that much
if it's doing anything really uh so here
we have king to g1 by nipple and now
rook captures an e1 of course we want to
get that rook away uh rook captures and
now rook to b8 now we're preparing rook
to b2 and then we're gonna we're gonna
have a beautiful rook here a beautiful
knight here and we're still asking white
what is the queen really doing on a6 and
nippo agrees he says i have no idea he
plays queen back to d3 and the magnus
goes rook to b2 so now uh you you have
to figure out how to play this uh uh we
have a5 uh but now comes h6 yeah and uh
what do you do here well this bishop
says finally there there is a job that
even i can do please bishop the c1 but
now rook to a2 and now your a5 pawn is
hanging so you have to do something
about this bishop back to d2 this is uh
a very very sad bishop indeed and now
queen to b7 now the queen can be
lifted over to the to the second rank
and then put even more pressure on
white's position and if you want you can
play a passive move like rook to d1 and
then you don't have to worry about such
such things but still for example a6
we're going to play bishop t1 and now
queen b5 and you never want to capture
here it's just a better position for
black but okay it it could be played
however nepal says i'm not playing any
of that uh passive stuff i'm going for
rook to e8 and now i want to get my
queen into the attack somehow it's not
yet clear how but if magnus wants the
attack he's also going to have to
activate his queen this is what magnus
does he plays a queen to b2 now puts
pressure on the bishop here so bishop to
e1 guarding the f2 pawn this is very
important and now knight to f4 attacking
nipples queen on d3
so now you want to get the queen into
the attack somehow maybe via the f5
square also you could do it via the a6
square so nipple decides to do it via
the a6 square and now this is uh the
moment where magnus really has to figure
out what to play uh he decides to
capture the pawn on d4 but just for fun
as this is a rapid game i'm going to
show you what happens after a move like
rook to a1 it's really a tricky move
because the rook on e8 is not kind of
stuck guarding that bishop and if queen
to c8 going for some checks here you
just play knight to g6 and now after
this one check is given you're gonna
play king to h7 and you don't really
have to worry about all that much the
bishop here is hanging it's hanging with
temple so rook to e8 will be played and
now some like queen to b4 and his game
over white resides here so uh something
also also possible after rook a1 because
white simply does not have time for
ideas like queen to c8 but okay magnus
played queen captures on d4
and now we have queen to c8 uh if you're
wondering about uh queen captures on c6
it makes sense because this is not a
pass pawn of course this is very strong
but now we're going to play rook to e2
now just threatening to pick up this
bishop here and after a move like queen
to a8 guarding the rook and also
preparing rook to ga to check we can
trade here for example captures captures
and i'll just queen to d5 we threaten
checkmate and there's no good way to
take care of this you have to play f3
then the c5 pawn falls away to check
then the a5 pawn falls and now you're
just up two pawns in a completely
winning position white has no uh
no plans here you know whatsoever so uh
instead after queen captures on d4 queen
to c8 right away was played and not
queen captures on c6 and now magnus just
plays knight to g6 makes sense we want
to take away these two squares from the
white rook uh and you know just enjoy
our attack we're going to go after the
pawns next we're going to put pressure
on the bishop next and this is our plan
so this is a very very delicate position
and uh imagine you are defending this
with black i'm gonna ask you to pause
the video here and try to find uh pretty
much the only uh viable defense here for
for white because white is not attacking
here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
very very awkward idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook the g8 check king to h7 and now
rook captures and g6 that's the that's
the point because now if the pawn
captures if the pawn captures queen e6
and you're not uh getting out of a
perpetual check here so this is just a
dead draw so black would have to capture
with the king here and then nipple
continues with tricks queen to g8 check
king to f5 queen to c8 check now if you
go back and never just repeats uh so you
have to go forward king to e4 now queen
captures on c6 which check king to d3
and now queen to f3 with chicken finally
after king to c4 we push c6 and now
we're down the exchange but we have this
very very strong pass pawn here uh which
could allow us to
maybe do something but it's still very
very hard so this is the only way for
black
for white to defend properly in this
position but it's a rapid game of course
this was not played nipple played queen
captures on c6 and now uh well now
simply there's no going back so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only correct way to continue this
for magnus to achieve a win while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on you know
considering all of the good ideas that
are possible in this position like queen
c4 rook to c2 but to those of you who
found the only winning move
congratulations you have just beaten
nipple for the first time in your life
and that move is of course rook to a1
that's the good stuff now uh what can
white play here well obviously the rook
can't really move and if you continue
with something like queen to c8 to try
the same idea of just rg8 followed by
captures uh it doesn't work just queen
c3 and that's it white resigns uh
because after this check king h7 you
don't have this because this is hanging
with tempo so uh
there's simply no time for such things
so here we have queen to e4 nifo offers
a queen trade also adds another defender
to d1 square but now queen captures on
c5 magnus just grabs another pawn king
to h2 unpinning so now the bishop can
move but now comes h5 with queen to e3
again offering a queen trade now queen
to c6 uh so putting pressure on that g2
pawn if the knight ever comes to the f4
or h4 squares it's going to be
very very difficult to defend this so
bishop to c3 trying to put some pressure
on magnus's position but now rook to a4
also the rook is attacked on a1 so rook
to a4 and now we have f3 so this does
block this diagonal but it weakens this
file so magnus just goes back rook to a2
now king to h1 on uh you know just
getting away from that second rank
otherwise you're gonna have to worry
about things like queen captures and f3
in the future if the white queen moves
from e3 so rook to c2 attacking the
bishop twice bishop back to e1 and now
queen to b5 with the simple idea of
queen f1 uh putting pressure on the
bishop also threatening queen to g2
checkmate so bishop has to move
somewhere bishop to g3 and now a queen
to f1 can be met with queen to g1 so
this is a bit
too soon magnus plays h4 and now there's
really no good square for the bishop
here if you go up the board then just
queen to b1 check and now if you block
just rook to c1 wins the queen in the
game and of course if king h2 just wrote
the c1 and there's no defense against
this checkmate so after h4 bishop the h2
was played but this kinda takes away the
very important h2 square from nippo's
king so magnus played queen to b1 check
bishop to g1 and now there is actually a
force to check made in seven and i'm not
going to ask you to find it because i
know you guys see it right away and that
of course is queen to f1 this is what
magnus played and he was in this
position on move 47 that iannipolishi
resigned the game and magnus won his
first game against nepo in 14 years and
10 encounters this is their 10th
encounter altogether
played in 2016
and yeah you resign because there's
simply no way to defend against queen
capture sanji to checkmate uh you know
you could play some silly moves like
trying to prolong the game but we're not
gonna discuss those there's really no
elegant way to prolong the game you just
have to play you know barbaric moves
uh so yeah this is carlson's first win
against nipple uh
first of many one would say but you'd be
surprised it's it's actually nipple who
who who's leading um uh in classical
games but okay this is rapid so you know
we're not counting that
but let's see uh how the other players
fared in this competition because this
is the world rapid championship so let's
check out that uh nope not that uh this
is the one so the world rapid
championship in 2016 in qatar aloha was
won by none other than vasily manchuk
followed by alexander grieschuk and
magnus carlsen so all three of them went
11 out of 15 but
i even shook with
best additional criteria i don't know
which uh the the criteria exactly it was
but i know he defeated magnus in their
uh rapid encounter and also in the blitz
encounter so uh vastly when chuck
crushed magnus in this um
event uh winning both blitz and rapid
games so you can see magnus in third
place here and nipple in sixth place
here and here are the standings from the
blitz section so you can see magnus tied
for first place with sergey karjakin but
uh karjakin uh won the
first place prize as i believe he also
won their uh
encounter uh with daniel dubov in third
place and then you can see all the way
uh in twelfth place i believe it's a
yanni pomnishi below peter lyco there
so there you have it magnus doing fairly
well tying all
well basically tying for first place in
both rapid and blitz nepo not as close
but also very very close
so this is the 2016. uh we're going to
see what happens next in their mutual
encounters and well then we'll see what
happens in november
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it and that you found uh well at least
one if not both of the poster video
moments i would like to thank jean
francois bond and matthias bollinger
oliver nichols the hoodie guy and the
win machine for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on these two
fine gentlemen checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day